let's bring in elena vettelinovic she's
at the department of health forest today
uh good morning to you uh it is going to
be an issue isn't it as we uh carry on
into
2022 staff absences
good morning jonathan that's right and
that's why boris johnson has tasked his
ministers to really stress test their
sectors against the covered absences and
work on the assumption that there may be
that worst case scenario that up to 25
percent of staff might be off sick or
isolating because of the virus we're
told that steve barkley the chancellor
of the duchy of lancaster is regularly
meeting with ministers to work out the
impact of omicron on the workplaces and
the supply chain but disruptions are
already happening we know that train
services across the country have been
impacted because of covered absences
also here in victoria station one of the
operators southern has to totally
suspend its services which will impact
not just uh commuters who go to uh the
cities in this on the south coast like
brighton and portsmouth but also the
commuter belt around london and the key
workers that need to get to work now
when it comes to the nhs we also heard
that in the last month the number of
hospital staff were either sick or
isolating has doubled now school
holidays are currently happening at the
moment so the problem there is that we
are not sure
how many teachers may have caught curvy
over christmas and of course the
government really wants to avoid going
back to
home schooling which has been so
detrimental to so many young pupils but
nonetheless school leaders have quite a
lot of concerns about covid in the
classroom take a listen to what some of
those concerns are
the difficulty for the people i
represent school and college leaders is
they won't know until tuesday morning
eight o'clock when they start to get
phone calls as to how many staff have
tested positive and therefore will not
be coming in school and it's not like
we've got lines around the block of
supply teachers who can suddenly at the
last minute step in to do that that's
the biggest risk i think to us having no
disruption
now the health secretary sergeant javid
has said yesterday that the government
will only introduce more restrictions in
the most extreme of circumstances but
authorities do acknowledge that despite
the accelerated booster programme the
sheer number of omicron infections means
that we are likely to see some
disruptions to public services in the
weeks to come